[Music]
foreign
action um grace
my new chief of staff
chief stress of staff no robot girl boss
in charge no
no why does our gender have to be in our
job description
when someone's like comedienne i'm like
what
like you're frosh all of a sudden like
i'm good
um grace my new assistant but i think we
call now chief of staff
sure so that it's like i mean i'm like
secretary i prefer secretary
you're dressed like one you kind of look
like you're like
from 50s poland thank you
that's actually exactly the aesthetic
that i'm going for so true
and uh uh before topher grace uh who is
coming on
uh is our guest on the show today which
is very exciting he's
um been on starred in that 70s show and
then went on to play david duke the guy
can do anything
and we've been friends for a long time
so he tells a lot of embarrassing
stories
uh about um my um
just catastrophic uh disastrous
choices in my twenties um so but we we
decided today before all that that we're
gonna do
an employer review as i put makeup on
uh because i will complete today um so
grace is going to give me some feedback
on me as a boss
we've been bullied into having to listen
to younger people
and i'm down good i'm ready to listen
i appreciate that i want feedback i do
not want to get cancelled for a toxic
work environment which is now just like
having fun
means you're toxic um so i i
i see friends getting fired and
cancelled and
in trouble and sued they away luggage
lady was ousted from her own company i'm
noticing as you're saying this you're
adding a button you're buttoning one
more button
on your shirt this actually is a great
lead into my first point
uh first of all thank you for coming
okay thank you normally barely
you did barely uh show up i did walk
into the room while your alarm was going
off
well as you tell the story can i put
uh hair coloring on my grace gree uh
blue to cover the
it's just a paste the least of it to
cover my graves while you're talking
is this insulting no no no go oh that's
a cool color oh thank you
thank you i mean like if it wasn't now
10 years ago i'd say can you please
apply this to my hair but i'm not going
to do that anymore
so i have to do it myself you can only
sing that because we're on camera you
can do that to my pubes okay what were
you saying
um so the the button i don't have pubes
and you know that that's true
um the buttoning up it's like a barbie
doll uh but the binding of
the shirt there's just or kendall it's a
lot i mean
there's just no there's nothing nothing
to see here folks
so the the buttoning of the shirt and
then um what i assume
can only eventually lead to an
unbuttoning of the shirt for you to
address that problem
uh brings me to my first point which is
a nudity
okay uh typically not encouraged or
allowed in a corporate work environment
okay okay okay
um okay tell that to me more made a
career okay
fair um uh yeah the number of times i've
seen
you nude instead of setting to you this
morning are you do
no you're misogynist i know i don't
that's true you don't respect the human
the female form that's
yeah correct so you're disgusted by my
body yeah absolutely so isn't that toxic
that's why we get along yeah no but um
but why who why
i remember britney spears security guard
came for her because she was naked all
the time was like dude take the win
oh yeah absolutely what is this you
should be so lucky how dare you you got
to see britney spears naked
yeah and you're complaining every every
man my age who like watched the toxic
video and felt something for the first
time in their lives
should be so lucky so so what's wrong
with me being naked as i
i as i am by my shirt wearing my
minimizer bra
because i didn't want my to be you know
like um my uh pendulous tits to be like
swinging around during our employer
review but i am gonna
get this so i wore a minimizer bra thank
you i've not worn a button-down shirt in
easily a year and a half
that's a lie you wear a button shirt
every day
yeah but i never button the top button
because i'm not a dork
sorry continue didn't call you a dork no
you didn't didn't but
on the nudity point to be fair you did
say in my interview you were like
i'm going to be naked i did i did it
listen this is a i mean i am naked
half of the day it's part of the job and
you know what
i'm finally at a point where i'm proud
of like
accept my body unconditionally and if
you can't grace no you have a great
problem you let me know
you should you kind of said that like
you're you inflected up which is what
people do when they lie i live in
i've worked in hollywood for 15 years i
know what lies sound like
okay i've been exposed but where
but where is like if i'm just wearing a
bra and i change my shirt because i
sweat a lot
that's true
you're making it too easy for me but i'm
saying what like
would you ever like leave this job
because you're like oh she's just always
naked
no absolutely not and i'm i'm very like
i don't care if anybody
sees any part of my body yeah i i mean
if you are having strong sexual urges
towards me
and i need to you know hide my body
that's a separate comfort that's like
that's an off podcast
i don't know i i don't like if you're
falling in love with me you just let me
know that's a red table situation
we could take that there i am so naked
all the time because i also get
distracted halfway through getting
dressed
that's true that is so true that's
usually what it is it's like even like
when i'm not even here
you'll be getting dressed and you'll
facetime me while you're getting because
that's apparently when you do your best
thinking and you'll be like so i was
thinking about the trip to spokane
coming up and the flights
i really think and i'm like okay this is
great um you're in pain
so i do appreciate that can you please
take off the corset harness
that whatever kinky shit you were just
doing but i do feel like in the
interview
because i've i've had many people work
with me and i'm learning that
if you as long as you manage
expectations like i say like i'm gonna
be naked a lot
you're gonna have to deal with dogs and
dogs you were super upfront about
everything
yeah i'm nothing has surprised me so far
okay
besides the first time i my first day of
work when you almost killed me
on the 101 okay so i did which brings us
to driving
okay one thing that is concerning it's
not necessarily like a toxic thing but
you'll be like okay i'm heading out like
i'm driving somewhere and i'm like cool
and then you will send me
multi-paragraph texts from what i can
only assume
is the freeway um and
then and then you'll voice me and be
like sorry that was just getting too
hard i'm like you already sent like four
or five texts
sorry texting and driving is just like
such a hassle
in los angeles sorry i am eating a
breakfast mcmuffin and i have not taken
my paper
from your space which brings me to oh i
have
um which brings me to sometimes i
do not take my prozac that's true and
then it's weird because i'll go
like greece didn't tell me to i'm like
that's not her like how would she know
if i took my prozac i can set a calendar
alert
but if i'm being weird just i probably
haven't taken my progress yeah for sure
um me on the freeway okay
texting i do sometimes do a voice like
you do often do voice memo but it's
usually preceded by a few
i know some protection drive you'd make
mistakes and it's like
you know i'm a perfectionist it's better
to focus on two things at once
okay so i will stop texting and driving
um this is this next point is
something that you you are very
self-aware about um and it's the vague
like vaguely sexual name calling i do
say baby i do call girls
mama got but i do it to guys oh i know
it's actually worse
it's funny it's like it's so degrading
it's so degrading and i'm not doing it
on purpose like i do
not try to uh emaciate men on purpose or
be
i i mean it's just i do i another
another thing that i don't think would
generally be allowed in corporate
america is having your employees working
in an active construction zone okay
yeah we are in under construction
in this house but also hey
what do you want to do because if you
want to work in television you're
working literally
studios are full of asbestos everybody
gets sick all the time
black mold everywhere basically the
stages that you're on you get
so sick all the time and the workers get
sick because they work overnight because
they have to
build sets overnight and when you're
making like a multicam to come like a
two
bro girls just my favorite show um no
like a seinfeld or a friends or any of
that
you're sometimes writing up until the
day before you shoot
so they're building sets and then you
just walk into like a sawdust zone
it is most tv and work environments are
incredibly dangerous not just physically
um you won't just get sexually harassed
you will also
get pink eye amazing um so yeah
i mean well and the co that i
corporate world i don't like i feel like
the tv world is
that i won't ever what am i going to go
work at goldman sachs you're the one who
wanted to talk about
corporate america i just mean like what
is go
what is going to get me what are you
going to put in your book
in 10 years that like was the craziest
done i mean we're only like two months
in okay guys topher grace is on the show
we're gonna shut up i'm having too much
fun
um i do want to tell you can you pull up
some tour dates there have been some
changes in the tour dates okay so first
text me for updates on this eight one
eight two three nine seven five two
seven
gracie over here um sends out the
updates so if you text us here i've been
saying this for a year and a half
but with so many tour dates coming up
and shows being added we'll text
directly to your city so i don't have to
annoy everybody
by blasting on the main feed like i come
into pensacola like and then all of you
have to see it and then you mute me and
then
um i you know hate myself
um will you start with the tour dates so
i can find the new ones yeah
uh riverside iowa we are coming to
you is that a real place
um yes absolutely it is uh the riverside
casino is there and that's where you're
gonna be playing on
thursday october i'm gonna be gambling
with my emotions
tickets are on sale when this comes out
so go get them
april 15th to 17th we're in spokane
washington uh that's next weekend that's
are we done we have to celebrate this
episode will air the day before we head
to spokane so
if there are tickets left at that point
which there are not many left so if
there are
go buy them um we added so many shows
so that all of you could come hang out
with us and i'm staying on the lake so
don't try to find me in the hotel i
normally stay in i'm just staying
an hour away in a lake so come drown me
down
you're helping april 22nd to 24th i'm in
san antonio uh
the laugh out loud comedy club uh we'll
be doing an unveiling
of the new name of the club when i'm
there uh that's a joke
april 30 through may 1 raleigh
raleigh improv it's actually isn't it in
kerry technically yes it's correct it's
such a beautiful venue
it is i was there maybe like three years
ago and i spray my ankle on stage so
anyone who saw that please come back and
watch me not hurt myself
uh it's such a gorgeous venue i'm super
excited and also send us ideas of what
we should do in each city because i um
we're going to be shooting some content
we're going to be fun that's the new
thing every city i go to i'm going to
like
skydive or like commit suicide or
something fun
may 7th and 8th i'm at brea california
comedy club we are adding
shows yes houston texas may 13th to 15th
houston
improv may 20th to 22nd dallas
in between those i have five days where
i'm probably gonna stay
in austin and do some shows there
uh to be decided tbd
uh uh phoenix arizona i'm there for like
a week and a half doing a ton of shows
may 29th
to june 3rd cb live are they sold out if
i'm if they are i probably shouldn't uh
no
okay wow
uh because i think we added like a lot
of shows so tempe
june four through six we're at the tempe
improv um i
i the you know you go to the website why
am i you guys know what to do you're
adults
i just don't feel like people go to
websites anymore they don't could you
have told me that i look like a
full like crack whore who robbed a pimp
i mean i look insane today i don't think
you look insane yeah this is enabling
uh it's gonna be a problem um grace
stan dot hathaway yes at on instagram
don't she's very different do not be a
creep do not send her photos of your
dick
please send them to me um i will
actually appreciate them and you know
that she will uh whitneycomings.com
someone stopped me stop this no you're
done cut
cut it i'll just keep talking don't
write elephants though
toe for grace is here the first thing i
ask every guest
is are we friends we are not
hollywood friends we are actual friends
and i can say that about
um very few people but uh but i
you're a very loving person so i'm sure
everyone who comes on your show feels
very loved and take care but i
you are like we really go back i mean
you
know me know me well we were we were
much younger kids
i think we probably met when i was 21 or
22.
truly yeah i mean i'm older than you but
uh but it was
we were you know yeah we could we're
going to wax on about it for the next
track
i'm going to because i love talking
about my youth it's like
it's you're chasing the dragon always
because it's so amazing but the thing
about you
and i was thinking about this because
having you come on it was like what do
we talk about we have so much to talk
about and
like we can't just make this inside
jokes the entire time and like all
remember when we made this
because we because everyone's just like
they're such fucking dorks like
remember when we made homemade ice cream
and made an omelette by accident
the truth is uh yeah if anyone's tuning
in for some crazy
2004 hollywood insider stuff but this is
why this is
what i truly credit so much of my
success to you
and let me tell you why all right let me
tell you because you were like
you were probably like one of the first
famous people
on a giant tv show that i met when i
came in and was actually friends like
became real friends with
and i lo i saw like oh if you're famous
you like
don't do drugs all the time you hang out
with friends that aren't necessary you
didn't hang out with only celebrities
you had real friends from childhood
you were on time at work like if i had
literally
linked up with any other famous person
that at that time i would either be like
dead or have like
nine bastard children with harvey you're
basically like oh being famous being a
loser like yeah that was that was me
yeah
but not but instead by the way to this
day but also there is a
but but the fact that you have been so
sustainab such a sustainable career and
have such an amazing reputation like
if i had linked up with any other dad at
that time i would have been like oh you
do drugs and you
you know this i would have gone down the
wrong path i learned from you like be
responsible
work have good friendships have a stable
life
go to outdoor screenings at the cemetery
like we were like
partying but we weren't like going
people off camera rolling their eyes
it does sound really nerdy yeah you're
saying you were in your 20s in hollywood
and you were doing all this no i'm
telling you you had
you were the star of one of the biggest
shows on tv
could have been going to any club or
festival or doing whatever
and we were doing healthy and being
nerds and like making homemade ice cream
and watching star wars
it was very um i feel they're lucky
yes i mean i do too uh i feel the same
way about you and i also
and a lot of people that were in that
crew we kind of rolled around rolled
around
but we never left home with i could have
very easily hooked up with a stephen
door for uh
um sure uh who else could have paulie
sure
whatever i should be so lucky i mean
let's be honest i wasn't hot enough for
him yeah let's not let's not get cocky
it's not that i didn't try i did try
numerous times um but i'm gonna tell you
what
i i'll return your comment with i i i
really was careful about who i let into
my circle because it was a weird time
you know i that was my first acting gig
someone had found me in a high school
play
so i was very what was the play the play
was a funny thing happening in the forum
but it was a really rinky dink
version of it at uh boarding school
whatever it was a long story but i
a lot of kids on the show had never
acted before and
i was very careful about who i let in so
it wasn't like um
a coincidence that we were hanging out
or you know i really wanted to be sure
that the people who i knew something
weird was happening or that it was
you know like a like everyone talks to
you like you're winning the lottery when
you go
i mean i mean i never acted i never
auditioned for anything before
but then when you're in it you go man
this doesn't feel like the lottery
uh you can't tell anyone because they're
gonna be mad at you for
it's you yes yeah exactly you
complaining just sounds like bragging
yes people but but i just knew like oh i
just got to be really careful and
there's so many cautionary tales i don't
know why people
aren't more careful but uh and i was i
was just i was thinking about you
because i've been talking i've been
thinking about this or talking about
this a lot about how so many
actors have become so known for their
off-camera life
that no matter how good their acting is
it's still hard to buy them as whatever
character
it's just like dude i mean it happened
whatever this is
opinion of my own it was like ben
affleck everyone was like he's a great
actor but when he was dating jennifer
lopez anything he did you were like
but you're dating jennifer lopez you're
not married to connie burton like it was
just like
and uh when you played david duke i mean
i even
know you dude and i'm like if we knew
any more about his personal life and how
like
kind and nice and normal there's a whole
side that you didn't know that that
really tapped into
but i was able to tell you i was able to
believe it i was like
um and uh and so many actors don't
understand that no matter how good their
performances are
if we know if you're too demystified
we're just not going to buy your work
let me tell you how i feel doing a
podcast and about you telling me that
because i'm so you'll as you'll see
by the way your instincts about being
private remember that you didn't have
email till like four years ago i swear
to god
you did not have an email but you you
say it and i'm very
glad i did that because i loved acting
so much and i didn't want people to know
and i also
loved my privacy so much but there was a
family guy that i was watching i think
my wife we weren't married at the time
but she was in the room with me we were
watching it and there's a scene where
they say to uh peter
you're flying on a private jet and it's
like i don't know why he got some
private jet to go somewhere they're like
this is such an amazing private jet
that it comes with a celebrity
oh my gosh so i so tell for grace walks
if someone else was doing my voice or
something but this character
you know it's me and uh family guy
cartoon
and he says hi i'm topher grace i'm a
celebrity who comes with this jet and i
i'll you know my life's an open book
i'll tell you anything about me
personally or career-wise
ask any questions and peter goes no i'm
good
first of all great joke and also that's
the flip side is like i have been
so uh quiet about that stuff that it is
like
i am whatever the opposite of that ben
affleck thing is like i am
because i am that guy i really uh but
there was a reason you were
like i mean you did like traffic
like like i love the work but i but i am
so boring and only now that i'm in my
40s i'm like really comfortable with uh
how boring aren't you psyched though
with everything that's happening
and all the people that are getting in
trouble for this they did 15 years ago
that you were like dude i was
we all can bear witness that you were
watching star wars and making cupcakes
on a friday night yeah yeah
yeah there's not even like a bottle
service girl that could be like he was
weird with me it's just like there's
nothing that is the silver lining you
know how boring i am yeah do you know
about the
actor that looks exactly like you don't
don't talk about me let's talk about us
i really mean i i'm here because i i am
so
i am so thrilled with the people that i
connect with first of all when they've
gone on to such success
i mean you were not supposed to
go on to this level of success i mean in
your own opinion
yeah and like none of us i remember some
of the people we're hanging out with
have gone on to such great things
but it tickles me to be sitting here in
this house and but you know what's cool
i mean everyone in our that friend group
i would say
70 percent i mean of that like eight
people we were hanging out with
are legitimately like at the top of
their field
and i don't think it's a coincidence
that we were like kind and consistent
and we had this like real uh this family
like we built this little family we
would hang out every
i mean i didn't always go to the tapings
i think i only went a couple times
because i always felt like that was
weird and i never wanted to seem like a
star
or something that was because you knew
deep down you were going to be very
successful that's what happens to people
who i think are
linda wallam ended up writing on my show
eight years later
yeah if she had seen me in your green
room just like a chicken head
like trying to meet celebrities there's
something to that you know what i mean
like i remember going it's
serious i went to like uh when traffic
came out i went to a party
and i felt bad because i was it was one
of those parties where
everyone was like literally everyone i
couldn't believe i could only tell
people who wasn't there who was a
celebrity wow you know what i mean like
there were so many celebrities there i
was like the only person i didn't see
there was george clooney
yeah but uh i left feeling rotten and it
wasn't because i like wanted to be a big
celebrity or something but it was
because i went
i wanted my work to matter more and yeah
i'm sure that's the same thing you were
feeling
well i think also for me i mean i think
my brain was always wired
as a comedian and i and you have to you
know for art to imitate life you have to
have a life
and when i would be around celebrities
it all felt like artifice and it all
just
it all just felt like i'm trying to
impress you or make you like me and i
i'm not observing real human behavior
because you guys don't know what
real life is like you know you don't
probably don't know how your atm code
like you know so for me the hanging out
with quote unquote normal or just not
famous people
it's just always way more interesting to
me yeah because it's like i already know
everything about you i have no questions
for you
i'm saying that's true yeah yeah we you
can't relate to me i can't really
achieve like but you did come you did
come to a couple tapings
i did come to a couple tapings and uh
and i definitely
credit seeing you on a multi-cam
and like how cool that cast was with
going when i did
start making television shows being like
you know i'm gonna do a multicam like
there's so much more fun the energy is
so great
um you're putting on a little play
yeah you know and but by the time i did
it there was
uh you were like a pariah if you made a
multicam you like weren't cool
you were like you know i was like they
put my show like after the office or
like the lead and for the aw
i was gonna become another thing dude
that was between like community in the
office so it was like
the cool kids would watch community and
then i'd be like hey guys here's my
jokes we
thought about that on this show that i'm
doing now which is what is the next
thing because it's i think what happened
was
i'm gonna track this but i think this is
what happened uh
the larry sanders basketball one of the
best
i mean i think that's the first one and
then the office
from larry said the british office from
larry sanders and then
the american office from there and then
modern family from the you know what i
mean it was kind of all
going to that document well and we can't
forget the comeback
i feel like the comeback god the
comeback talk about linda he's
yeah talk about linwood
yeah mike sure was on the first season
to come back so crazy but yeah because i
think that although that show wasn't
like
you know now it's become i think bigger
like everyone it's like sort of a
sleeper hit
um but uh and lisa kutcher should have
gotten all the awards like it didn't she
is
she's it like we actually uh shout out
to lisa kudrow
who who didn't do our show
but uh we wanted to have her come play a
role on it and i thought
we wanted to have someone who was like
the like someone asked me like what is
the
biggest baller in terms of sitcom that's
alive and i actually think it's lisa
kudrow it's 100 lisa kudrow and i just
got to do a pilot with her at amazon and
it didn't go because uh
we we we you did a pilot yes with lee
daniels
um and i created um and this didn't go
it did not happen
yeah well because a lot of these
streamers now and so i'm so excited that
you're doing a show on
a network i i feel like we all we're all
we're like
networks they they don't let us do what
we want we can't and then went to the
streamers and the streamers were a
creative haven for artists for maybe
like two years
but then yeah the pendulum swings then
they realized they were making shows
internationally immediately so all of a
sudden your content
had to appeal to china and america at
the same time where it used to be we got
to make
eight seasons and then sell it
everywhere else you know that's right
and we were exporting american culture
now it has to sort of work
so also i think it's exclusive it's like
uh
streaming is and maybe something should
be exclusive you know what i mean like
certain um
uh nightclubs you want to make them
exclusive because people want to get in
it makes it very cool but
it kind of i think depends on the tone
of the show some of them you really
don't want them to be exclusive you want
anyone
who can get a tv for free to see it
right but you and i have done that we've
done the shows that appeal to everybody
and check every quadrant so for me it
was like
you know which is like largely part of
the reason that i'm kind of like taking
time off of
creating shows because i was like okay
i've done the four quadrant ones like i
got to do two multicams like i know how
to do that i love that now i kind of
want to do something that's more aligned
with
my taste and who i am as a comic and
i had this deal with hbo and we made a
pilot and it was like too edgy
or two too edgy for hbo yeah they wanted
to be more like whitney i love it
well jenna jameson was in it this was
what it was
it was a show where um
about a couple who out of nowhere
the woman the female started making more
money than the guy and it was about how
he
the power dynamic gets up and how did
not um it's a documentary
and basically of how uh it's
emasculating by accident and then how
she has to minimize herself and then
um i wanted to really uh go into the
biological basis for this in the
biological basis so
uh i wanted to do a device that showed
what it was like
how we actually get information now
because i was sick of all these shows
where it's like every time you need to
find out information um it's like two
girls at yoga class being like well you
just need to get a makeover or they're
like in spin class being like you know
what you need to do you need to like
spice it up in the bedroom it's like why
like no one talks in exercise glasses
what are you doing like they're doing
you full yoga like upside down like you
know what you should do
and i was like i don't want to do this
expository
best friend role thing so what you would
actually do is go
you'd watch a ted talk right or you'd
watch read a book or a self-help book or
you go to a therapist or whatever so
what i did was i had actual an actual
neuroscientist
in it as an actor who would everything
would freeze if the character had a
question
and he would come in well like in a like
in a annie hallway like he
kind of talks about yeah like literally
yes very much so um
without the creepy behind-the-scenes
behavior yeah i mean i i just watched
that doc uh
not uh yeah no i don't like any
hollywood no but i also by the way i
i have a very hot take on annie hall i
used to be my favorite movie and
going up back and watching it i am
obsessed with diane keaton you are my
hero
to be fair that is not a feminist
character at all
only because she's wearing a fucking
vest dude
she's so dumb in the movie she's flighty
she's indecisive
she's dating a guy who is wildly under
her beneath her
uh she's like in the la da very cute but
it's like
say what you're saying she's like man
like she's like like
uh flighty and ditzy and it's just like
dude you're
35. pull this out she's 35 in it well in
it yeah whatever 30 i don't know yeah
i just felt like it was like looking
back at it she's like a silly bimbo
who can't put a sentence maybe played by
a great actress
you know i know what you're saying right
like the characters the character is not
what i thought it was like going back
i'm like oh wow she like
is she have tourette she's a stuttering
problem why can't she say a word
you know what i'm saying wait wait wait
wait before
how john and james how did that fit into
the yeah so that because you had me at
jenna jameson
i'm ready to see the file this is based
on a real thing that happened as soon as
i started making money or i stand still
it's never as much as you think like as
soon as you're on tv people think you
have a billionaire i wasn't really
around
you when you started making money i knew
you i knew so much of the prequel of
that
that's actually a question i had driving
here today was
what was that because i knew you after
two but
and by the way who knows no one knows
anyone when they're actually making
money because you're doing so much work
you don't see anybody that's right
that's right
but like but and you don't get to spend
that because you're not you're just
right you know what was that experience
like because you were like a lot of your
comedy came from like at that time
that has to and then all of a sudden
you're i mean you didn't
you made real money because you had a
piece of the thankfully
uh my parents who both had strokes uh
without health insurance and a couple
family members that
had to go into rehab immediately the
ones that are eighty thousand dollars a
month i wasn't
i didn't really i made it i just didn't
get to keep it my business manager was
like dude i've never seen
you forget forget the money money come
in and go out so quickly
i represent basketball players the
station the station and how that changed
how
like what was that like emotionally for
you because i'm sure it was really
interesting but you know what's weird
is that you again were in the back of my
head like i learned a lot
from you about how to manage things
enough people gonna hear this this is
the only time i've ever gotten
compliments is this great
when i first started making money i
started giving it all away and i started
forget the money i just mean
you're changing in station okay this is
important um
i'm not gonna let you reject my
compliment no no you're gonna receive it
and you'll receive it good
when i first started making money i had
been so broke for so long
and you guys had covered dinners for me
i mean i used to go to din uh dinner
with two of our friends jenny and dory
and i shout out to jenny and dory oh my
god
still my besties and i sell my girls
just great great people they're both in
my book
the shout out is the shout out is for um
uh jennifer goodwin jennifer was one of
the great actresses of our time
and dorian is one of them look like she
likes me for 15 years
dory howard is one of the great humans
of our time like just right here
i just those people i'm so lucky aren't
we so lucky we grew up around these
people
how gross so many people ended up like
the fact that i got to come to hollywood
and hang out with you and jennifer
goodwin salted the earth
and the kindest people you know you are
lucky those are really great people
like yeah yeah many times i would have
been if i didn't meet you guys
well i mean i think uh
let's be honest here's what i always
thought here's the thing okay let me for
the listeners for the listeners of this
show and the viewers of this show
here's some stuff i want to set straight
okay i want to set the record straight
because whitney's always
still crapping on yourself okay everyone
that i all the guys that i knew wanted
to hook up with
you and i never danced which is crazy
like we never even
thought about it well it's frankly a
little insulting no
you weren't you weren't either let's
just be honest here let's just
never any sexual energy never a invader
never a dru like we did new year's eve
together we got wasted like
never just a sloppy hook up like whoops
we shouldn't have done that like but
nothing in fairness all of my guy
friends
like tried to make a run at you and
what's crazy to me fairness they're all
fucking nerds
yeah i mean you probably shouldn't i'm
not telling you you should have done it
i'm not telling you
but i couldn't believe the guys that you
wouldn't get within the guys that you
would get with like that like fair
it's fair this is a fair criticism dude
i
one of dory's friends one of our friends
called me out of nowhere one day
and just was like can i set you up and i
was like what do you mean no i'm dating
someone he's like what is it with you in
these shady guys
you're always some shady guy that none
of us have ever met who's like in their
late
40s who's like like we don't we can't
even meet them
and like you know i was very sketchy
with my relationship life
but but i'm not attracted to healthy
people you're gonna say
i'm sure you talk a lot about your past
and these terrible guys over but there
were
so many guys who wanted to
be with you you were you were a hot
commodity
i mean i was also like a idiot
well sure i'm not i'm not denying that
at all but that looks bad
but i mean like let's be honest they
just i think you probably paint yourself
like
you were even at the time you were like
uh your whole thing is like you're so
down yourself you couldn't get a date
and i was like everyone wants to
get with you and you were you were just
very like you were dealing with all your
stuff
but i just know i was just like my
definition of a healthy relationship was
like being with some narcissist who had
three other girlfriends and lied all
that you know i mean like i was addicted
to the adrenaline of toxic relationships
and so anything that was healthy and if
if anyone was interested in me it was
like grossed me out
i i thought i had to chase i i wanted
uh men that like gave me adrenaline and
i conflated
uh so a lot of people a lot of people at
that age with passion
and it was really just fear and i was
dating really toxic
uh abusive people and drug addicts and
stuff like that and your friends were
all healthy and well adjusted and i was
like no thank you
i couldn't receive love at the time but
you but you did through the
women who were in that group called
friends and they were and that's
wonderful
because uh that's where it starts i
guess right yes for sure
i mean ginny and dory taught me how to
be a human being just because they were
so healthy
i don't have chapters on them well you
might get confused because i did change
uh ginny's name to jenny i won't be able
to follow that at all yeah it doesn't
make any sense
i really wanted to uh protect her uh
anonymity in this
and then dory oh dory i think it's just
named dory
oh look at that my education about
breasts was an episode of who's the boss
i i mean the references are very i'm
just gonna skip just to those chapters
yeah
i do i talk about uh getting my uh uh
breast implants and not telling anyone
when i first made money and i went to
some guy
by the airport because i didn't know how
where to even go i was too embarrassed
to ask anyone and none of my
friends got breast implants because
they're too normal and healthy so i
didn't have any friends that knew
and i i literally i went to beverly
hills drove to bedford which is like
the there's roxbury and bedford which
are all these like fancy doctors the
spot to get them i walked up and down
and just read the doors you know there's
like writing of the doctors on each door
and i just was like
cosmetic surgery and i just called and
then he
said great come in tomorrow never
get surgery from a surgeon that's
available tomorrow
this is what i want to say this is an
example of whitney saying i i didn't
have it together
everyone loved you everyone thought you
were great and the reason that we
probably never had a thing is because so
many of my guy friends tried and
failed for whatever reason and then you
were still friends with him that's what
was so great
that's that's interesting but anyway i
just want to paint a picture whenever
you're hearing all these stories about
whitney's past and look at this i'm sure
this book is full of them too first stop
ruining my brain
you're you're exactly you were uh you
had your
stuff together i mean i think i was at
my best when i was around you in that
crew
you guys didn't bring out the best in me
but i think that that really did prepare
me
uh as maybe pathological as it was or
weird as it was or
um uh fake as it felt or whatever um
it did prepare me for the comedy store
hallways of
30 male comics hitting on me or flirting
or
and i was like able to just be like boom
boom i was able to like turn things
platonic yeah you gotta have that's what
you have to do if people ask me about
why i was so
private then i actually i'm not as
private now just no one cares you know
like you care about
what's going on in a good way and people
care at the right time not at the wrong
time they care when you have something
coming out that's when you want the
attention that's right not when you're
walking down the street with a friend
and they're like oh she's cheating
like that's what you want but you gotta
have especially if you're going through
a
it's i mean your work should be more
interesting than your life or else
you're a reality star
i agreed with all that but on top of it
i think you need to have a home base
when you're younger
now i mean i have a home base you know
what i mean i'm like married i have kids
but at the time i think there's that
really dangerous age when you're in your
and you're saying you had at the commie
store you had like a home base
mm-hmm so you knew you know i don't have
to
be with this guy like you know like
because you had friends some
like i think if you feel that home base
you're you're inoculated a little bit
against some of that totally and it's a
skill
to not you eat i mean it's a skill you
have to learn for self-preservation you
know
you never did it you never dated one
person that you ever worked with i did
date
i did date i have not dated a stand-up
comedian
ever ever wow okay crystally and i never
dated
what is the definition of dating right
now um it's good you know it's a good
question because even when you said hook
up i was like is that i think that means
sex now
i don't even know what these kids call
it anymore but you know what you
really did just in terms of going back
to what happened with money
you had a very uh i don't know
primordial instinct or just
from on a cellular level maybe you had
made mistakes in your life with money
one time we were at i believe the magic
castle
we went to a lot of matches pretty nerdy
in this one yeah no no it's a strip club
the magic gun
did i say i meant jumbo's clown room
sorry
we were at like the magic castle or
something we were we were going to magic
castle
we were at the pirate restaurant whitney
what are you doing
no we were there for the cafe
disneyland we're like you know like the
kids are going to like the medieval
times and no they were going to shelter
and drink
club dream and all those club wet
whatever the
nightclub's names were here and uh shout
out to hartwell
um and uh and something happened where
you had to go and you didn't pay
you're like you always paid but this was
like we were have been friends for years
i don't i don't think i i don't know if
i paid the bill or something maybe i had
already done that lexus campaign because
i did one campaign where i made money
and uh you had to run out it was it was
melissa jenny it was for melissa
goodwin's birthday
and oh yes oh man i can't i don't think
i know to this day that i didn't pay
no no no no you did you tell him you
left
10 minutes later we were like oh tofu
just covered tofu you called and we're
like i'm coming back i need it
and you were so intent on paying it was
like four your
bit was like 40 and you were like no i'm
on my way and you got really
serious about it and i was like dude
just pay next time you're like no no i'm
headed back and like you came back
and paid and i thought about that and i
was like
i've thought about that a lot in my life
because i it took me a long time to
learn that
when you um money makes relationships
toxic
and well this is i mean segway the show
i'm on right now is literally just about
these three siblings and money and i
and it's it's what you're trying and in
doing press for it i'm like
people are asking me like should we talk
about money yeah should we not it's the
only taboo anymore besides race and
money
the most uncomfortable i can say what's
your favorite way to what's your best
lay like and
you can say that how much money do you
make i'm trying as you see when i
arrived here i was like yeah how much
are you worth this house incredible
like i want to start talking about it
more because it has to not be a thing
that's why i wanted to do roseanne
because that was always my favorite show
because they talked about money yeah
they talked about everything on that the
the original show
i mean like did that pilot going mind
blowing yeah you can't pay week and
how money makes things up and the fact
that your show is about that and that's
what i tried to do with two broke girls
and i think that's part of the reason it
did well
because there was nothing that a story
always had to be about money
b's story could be about relationships
but a story was always how we're going
to pay our taxes how are we going to get
this loan back how are we going to pay
for this
uh you know cavalry it's not real like
everyone's not going through it in the
world
it's the only thing with stakes at this
point it's the only thing everyone has
in common
and yet yeah it's this weird thing not
talking about it but
yeah i hope uh i hope some of these
shows because i was watching it and just
i mean and it it hit me because as
you know someone that came from a family
without a lot of money and then i
started making it
it's i it's destroyed a lot of my
relationships with my family members
it's a lot of you think you're better
than me what and then if i do loan the
money
then they're like oh you think just
because you loan me money and i'm like
no like there's no strings attached for
me
but it's hard to do healthy giving but
i'm obsessed with
that show even just uh your show i can't
wait to see it at home economics what a
genius title what a genius title these
guys the writers are who are they it's
uh mike colton and john a boot and it's
like a oh do you know
what excuse me you do know calling a
bird yeah yeah that's funny
sorry yeah i used to do best week ever
with colton in a boot on vh1
well they're they're they're even more
than that
i mean well no that's all been downhill
from there clearly
i was with them in their glory days when
we would don't talk about it when we
would make
500 a week uh doing one-liner jokes
about b-list celebrities on vh1
i forgot that you did that i mean i i'm
sure i think i met them because i was
a josh dumel and i for movie would do
with jennifer goodwin were on
the hot chicken movie no win a date with
todd hamilton well what did you think it
was called
there was hot shit there was chicken in
it right she worked at a chicken right
now
chinese worked in a chicken restaurant
in a movie no
no i she for sure was worked in a fast
food restaurant that movie no
she worked through like uh can i have a
piggly wiggly that's right
okay i have you know what else i have
not seen a lot of what my famous friends
have done and i think that's a good
thing
well i'm not asking you to watch that
movie no i won't don't worry
no it's a beloved movie but i i it's not
beloved
i know it is the guy that knew the guy
that i'm dating he goes he's like uh i
was like yeah tofu for tomorrow he's
like dude from when a date
he calls it win a date which is no way
that happened i'll call him right now i
will tell you one thing when i met my
wife
she was she's 10 years younger than me
and she was in
whatever the the small demographic at
i mean if i was if that movie count was
24 she was 14.
and that was like she never seen 70 show
but that was the movie that she
and to this day she thinks it's the best
thing i've been in and she loves it no
people
love that it is not the best movie okay
you okay just like how you debunked my
version of my past
you are wrong about this no i can bring
in some reviews of that movie that'll
prove that i'm right um okay we have a
little surprise for you if i can get
myself together
i love this one to get it all right
we're gonna facetime
someone can they see me
uh yes i think that's the goal let's see
let's see
oh what the fuck hello
this isn't a surprise i mean there's a
surprise but this isn't like uh from my
deep past
no it's not from your d-pass it's from
your deep future
i didn't know that uh this wasn't gonna
be yeah next
sorry uh how do you guys know each other
is it from the comedy scene yeah
i appropriate her culture regularly
sashir is sure i'm doing press for this
and this week i have been so
sappy about you guys like i really no i
mean you know the vibe there
like we're all feeling it but then to
say it feels really
icky it's like so true it's just so
earnest you know like you know what's
amazing about this could have
for any other group of people could have
gone horribly like to just facetime
someone's castmate
like most of them don't get along like
this that's such a genuine like
hey you're the you're here you got that
email from hr
part is the new funny people like they
like
and home economics has both we were just
talking about home economics
what a what a coincidence you're so good
on it i've now
seen more episodes than you you are so
about it but it was like three in the
morning when i saw you last what was
your audition experience did you
audition with with toe for
sure no i just said so it's an offer
okay wow i'm still having to screen test
four times
so we did we did get your calls about
being on the show with me but it was
kind of like
sorry we went a different way you know
maybe season four
i'm like don't you need a loud rich
apple isn't that what the
brother is like shouldn't i already got
one of those yes
wait because i have whitney tell me
about
like sashir is said you're such an
enigma like
you you first i i didn't feel like i
knew you until like halfway through
and then yeah you kind of revealed
yourself to me that's cause she doesn't
like you
oh is that what it was yeah no no no not
at all no
uh i can't remember how it came up but i
i'm i'm sarcastic and blunt but i wasn't
doing that with you because i just
didn't
know you that well and then you asked
about it or i was like
oh yeah i i can be pretty blunt and
you're like really and then i started
doing
like being nice because we're co-workers
and you're very supportive
but i love that that's fascinating
because i feel like i get
i hang out with comedians so much in
podcasts that i've totally
lost my ability to like communicate with
like no and i'll go into a set and i'll
be like hey
i'm like oh you can't do that anymore
like so i just like try to shut up and
sit in a chair and not get sued
yeah i well i'm like i don't really help
people out when i'm sarcastic i just
like
say something and i'm like good luck
figuring that out so i don't
i try not to do that and work all the
time because i don't people being like
does she
hate me or you know like just like not
knowing but now i know i
i now i know you know i do hate you you
do
for sure hate me on a daily basis i
that we got such a great got such a
great vibe on that thing like that's all
i know i feel so lucky it's like really
rare i mean i genuinely like everyone
there and it feels right it also shows
in the work i watched like the trailer
last night i haven't seen
um uh all of it but it was like the
chemistry it looked like season four
it's like when you're dating the odds of
you having a chemistry with someone are
so bad and you just gotta keep dating
it's like and the worse it gets the more
you have to keep it and then
at some point you actually although this
is like five people connecting
is so it's just so rare yeah so right
it's so rare
all right go go do your thing i'm sorry
i love you and we just were talking
about the show
because it looks amazing and it's a
destroyer cast
thank you i'm so glad thank you for
asking okay stop stealing my thunder
see you next week stop being funnier
than me thank you
the best we now take a break in this
lovely stroll down memory lane uh
and one that proves that i am actually
the age that i am thank god the only
reason
i brought topher grace here today um to
talk to you about
alo fresh shalom fresh
i love hellofresh bonjour fresh i get it
delivered right to my little house i
made i think i made this point
i made every meal oh that's awesome oh
no no but i had hellofresh
come to the house the other day the
vegetables were so crisp and delicious
they're amazing meals they're ready in
20 minutes or less very feminist
it's this is a way to be in the kitchen
as a woman but also have
stuff to do and they already give you
the meals they give you the recipes
everything's set up for you
and my lover whipped up
the most delicious pot it was like a
pasta alfredo
ginoki it was
is amazing gnocchi can go to
hellofresh.com good for you 12 and use
code good for you 12 for 12 free meals
including free shipping go to
hellofresh.com
good for you 12 and use code good for
you 12 for 12 free meals including free
shipping
america's number one mill kit you'd be a
moron not to
get this that's their slogan
look this is i'm not gonna lie to you
guys we've got
many lights in here we're basically
shooting this podcast on the surface of
the sun
because it makes me look younger you
guys always think that i'm glowing at
sweat
i know what is that shimmer you're using
that's pure
and but most deodorant i stopped wearing
deodorant
like six or seven years ago i noticed
because she had to move states i quit
because i was trying to get you to quit
and you just wouldn't go
now i use this because not only does
native includes ingredients you've
actually heard of
that you can pronounce if you can
coconut oil shea butter mm-hmm
and almost everything is vegan and
nothing is tested on animals
love it you can try native risk free as
well temperatures
starch can you eat i love pudding make
the switch to native today by going to
nativedo.com
whitney or use promo code whitney at
checkout and get 20
off your first order that's
nativedeo.comwhitney or use promo code
whitney at checkout for 20
off your first order and if you don't
buy native you stink
i was like nervous going in because i
was like
you know whatever especially if you've
done one before it's as you should be
and i i was straight up cocky two days
into it i was like oh my god i don't
even have to do anything like
it was such a click i don't mean like a
click
with a cue i mean like it just clicked
like we
really um i could just tell and then you
know what's crazy is the pilot's
i'm really proud of it but it just gets
so much better if you have that kind of
chemistry well i always say the pilot is
the worst episode it should never be it
kind of is
yeah that's the one where you're
figuring things out and you're like
making mistakes and it's informational
you have to say this character is this
this person
yes yes by the time how's life been
since you're divorced i know
it's like you have to do such cumbersome
like no one talks like that
you know but but the the
i mean it's so magic it's weird because
i think every project people come in and
say
it's magic and the cast is really like a
family and you know what but like truly
on this one
i was uh can i ask you a question this
is just a uh
not i mean because this is like uh you
strike lightning when something like
this happens when a cast just clicks
like roseanne had it
um beth i had it with crystal leah but i
mean we had been friends before
um where uh uh uh beth bears and kat
denning's had it on two birth girls
yeah they really you know yeah that's a
great example like and they were
actually best friends in real life and
it just but it's also a way that you're
surfing the laugh
and like your timing and the connection
it's like building attention
yeah it's like it's it's like when sex
just works i i don't know it's one of
those
like it is very similar to dating in
that sense and um
and it's and when it's when it's like
more than two people like that's
hard to find chemistry with two people
you're just jumping off a cliff with
a bunch of people and you have no idea
if it's going to work or people get
insecure they get jealous or
they because i think that sometimes when
you get on a set when there's fear
involved people just regress
to their inner child state and they
recreate their childhood circumstances
that's why people can be awful sometimes
yeah can we get some of this food
yes yes i eat while i'm doing this
apologies to the audience
you should be so lucky to hear topher
grace eat a fried chicken sandwich okay
this is gonna be on pornhub there are
people who tune in just to see you do
this
i'm telling this should also actually go
up on the only fans i feel like this is
going to get
this is called a mukbang eat it with
your feet yeah
i do have a perfect score on wiki feet
um
five out of five oh wiki feet is they
judge your feet they judge your feet
yeah
oh yeah yeah which is uh kind of a big
deal thank you mama
um uh i have a perfect score on wiki
feet
and so let me let me put the
conversation
let me direct the conversation a little
bit i think i was there the first night
you did stand up is that right
at embar yeah holy sh you were there the
first night i did stand up and so was my
dad by the way
um let me tell you something i can only
say this because you become
literally a name comedian like you're
like uh like i've seen
specials with you yeah you were bad that
first night
dude like that i was just like i think
you mean to say
terrible i was just like i know nothing
about the comedy world that was like my
first time in mbar so
or what is m cafe bar which was on vine
and fountain which is now
uh another place i didn't get it i
didn't get the people test out material
or what was it
i thought no i thought it was good i
wasn't testing it i thought that was my
final product after testing it many
times
uh in my mirror testing it no but here's
what the biggest mistake i made
and this is probably the reason i
stopped like we stopped hanging out a
lot because i was just like embarrassed
for 10 years
but like when you your first time you do
stand back i gotta invite all my friends
oh my god
stupid stupid that's what happened you
know and
richie went up and did better than you
oh dude richie
okay our good friend richie keane
brilliant brilliant director
the bit he used to do that was fucking
brilliant
is he had a joke about um when he would
go to starbucks and there were zucchini
muffins
and he had this joke about the guy that
has to cut the zucchini every morning
knowing that no one's gonna eat
but no one gets the zucchini muffins and
it was just like
it was such a random like amazing
observation
and i thought about that a lot like gary
goldman you know
does that incredibly well where he can
do 40 minutes on sugar cookies gaffing
you can do 50 minutes on hot pockets
but i like i always think about that bit
going like
everywhere you are you can find
something funny about the person that
made this thing you know like i think
about it
so he had not done stand-up for about
seven or eight years ago okay we're
going back to this yeah
still went up uh-huh and kind of crushed
and i remember
thinking like a whitney's like
like women aren't funny i knew it i
remember i remember just singing
you uh actually you know what i'll tell
you honestly because that's kind of like
the funny anecdote version but i
remember watching you
um figure no no i mean some of that but
like
figure out your thing and it's actually
when you see when someone becomes an
artist with it which is what you become
and you're actually i mean like books
and tv shows and
you know whatever it's really a
interesting thing to watch someone find
their voice i mean i don't
that's not something i have to do in my
career is like find my it's like i have
to do a different thing every time
whatever
but to watch you kind of like try
because first basically you were doing
what people do at mbar
with us and like telling us jokes and
some of them would
go well and not and then you collected
those and brought them in bar and then
collected those and brought
and like to watch the process and then
i remember when i saw the first like
billboard for one of your specials i was
like
what the fuck i mean it was like what
the fuck was comedy central thinking no
no i was like
they had to they had to meet the girl
quota thank god for these diversity
higher mandates
this is what you're doing but the truth
is i was like oh that's what hard work
is
like you like you know what i mean like
not like you were someone you were very
funny person
but i was like oh this is where it goes
from where the rubber meets the road you
know where it goes from being
i don't know comedians i mean i know a
couple from growing up and i didn't know
any of them as well as you
and it that's where it goes from you
know like
like like kind of around like we all
think we can be a comedian when you
watch
right to like oh this like she worked
down
you finally got one minute which
probably was well after the
the five minutes i saw and then you got
five minutes i mean that's how it goes
right and then
you were doing an hour right it was it's
one of the only businesses you know
louis ck
i think is who puts this the most
eloquently like where you succeed by
failing
like every night you fail like there's
no like like seinfeld goes out and fails
somewhere right
of course all the time because they're
going crazy and but he fails for
slightly different reasons
than a younger comic would fail he might
fail because someone's like i've already
heard this joke or
or you know because they just saw it if
you try stuff in front of a crowd
or they'll go like yes i we just want to
hear you talk about this that like
there's more expectations maybe he knows
if a joke's gonna work before he tells
it at his
station i think so like i mean when he
was i mean he did that documentary
comedian where
uh uh in the documentary he does like
five sets a night or something and one
of the
uh clubs he's not doing as well as he
should be doing and he's like
what do you guys know about comedy like
how like i
like this is a great joke like i know
that like you guys are failing here
you know so at every level you do
because either number one
your fans expect something from you or
the bar is even higher for you so
so i think there a lot of comedians try
to kind of coast on their fame for me
it's completely the opposite they're
like who's this
i see everywhere like you better be
funny you have to almost be twice as
funny
because people already experienced to be
funny you really are a uh
uh you're a part of that wave you know
and
uh uh women who are getting into comedy
now should be
should understand what it was like back
then it was really different and people
think i i this probably comes off very
sexist and not like woke or whatever the
most embarrassing word
um in the english language all of a
sudden but um
uh a lot of girls like young comics that
have been doing it two or three years or
like the company stores toxic and they
don't let
like i should you know why aren't i
getting spots in the main room like
because you're not good yet
and you should not be doing that yet
like you my biggest
regret almost is i sort of was seen too
soon as a stand-up before i was ready i
was certainly funny
i had a funny you said that back then or
you said no no no back then i'm like i
deserve it
right now and you know you get one
chance to make that first impression and
you know gary shandling told me one time
you can never make it too late as a
comedian as an actress you can probably
never make it too early make it too late
never
such a great question think of our
greatest community i mean ronnie
dangerfield made it at
68 or something like 55 or something he
was playing 68 yeah
the whole time right because he had a
life and he had a point of view
being a comedian is all about having a
point of view and surprising opinions
and life experiences
just let me think rodney dangerfield's
wife is like shut the fuck up
or was he even married i mean like i
don't even know i don't know but there
are famous stories about every meeting
he would take
he would wear a robe and open his legs
and his balls would hang out during the
meeting
and if someone but not in a sexy way you
know like as a joke i mean
it depends on what you're into i guess
if you're into necrophilia maybe
um and uh uh you know is it when you're
starting out like you're just getting
comfortable on stage nothing you say
is interesting or true it's as a woman
at the time all you would do is sex
stokes to try to like
neutralize yourself or make yourself
unsexy or ugly or
or you're trying to make the comics in
the back laugh like you go really like i
mean i had just like abortion jokes i
used to do this
like my first step i used to do this
joke that i was like i've never been
because i don't say no like i'm
unbelievable like i did
all this crazy she said hey i want the
audience to take themselves back to
my youth i'm not a comedian i don't even
really know comedians
and whitney comes over with some of my
friends who also like oh no i mean we we
had fun but we weren't trying and you're
like cracking jokes like that i'm going
like the fuck
this girl talking about and then after a
while i was like you know some of these
are like really funny but like
like it's 2 30. we're at brunch
on a sunday what do you do with that
interview but uh
it was like armor for me it was like by
the way aggressive
because you and i had some great talks
that were that were not that were you
you know what i mean what i thought was
like oh this is like hard work
over a period of time and i don't you
know people don't see the work in comedy
i'm sure they do on this podcast
but like the work it takes to get to a
place where you have something that is a
machine like that you know
ellen sitcom is one of my favorite
sitcoms ever um the first signal the
first to come
it's fucking excellent i haven't watched
that dude she did some
that was so wild first of all it was
there's an extra level of how funny it
is because she was playing a straight
person for seoul i mean she literally
dates jeremy piven on the show
like says it all right it's so funny in
so many ways now but she was always in
like a sundress and like sneakers like
looking back now it's just so funny yeah
a lot of sun dresses that's all i
remember i got to go watch that show
again
there was one so when friends started i
mean i love sitcom history and i'm just
obsessed with it but um
when uh janine garofalo one of my
favorite people on the planet
uh i was with bert christopher yesterday
and i said who's your number one hall
pass
number one hall pass your wife would
never get mad you could pick anyone he's
like janine garofalo
and we like went into a deep dive and i
was like i forgot she's amazing
dude she was so fucking hot and she was
she's on ellen
yes and i'll tell you this this episode
but like for like a guest star thing or
something she was a guest star
but uh jeannie groffalo remember when
she played like the ugly
friend on cats and dogs
[Music]
it's just so wild to look back and be
like what remember
bye bye love she was so good invite
she was like the grumpy dude reality
bites excuse me
excuse me can i tell you who's the
baller oh sorry i could go no please
don't shoot me don't do it we do not
shoot guests
oh all right is uh
i've really been thinking about ben
stiller's filmography as a director
dude and he is like people don't give
that guy
i mean he gets plenty of respect because
he's so famous as an actor
people forget just reality bites alone
that's just one of my top 10 favorite
movies of all time i'm sorry
dude the ben stiller show like i grew up
being obsessed with that i did
i love walter mitty by the way i think
that's like an unheralded light
and and tropic thunder but yeah he's
just some of the stuff he's doing now
is like he's dude that's that what's the
one on show time with uh escape from
patricia or cat right escape i mean dude
he's like also
bless his fucking heart award shows are
so boring i know he does it every time
he comes out and kills dude
every time he kills shows even the
golden globes which was just like an
awkward festival of weirdness
he crushed you with that banana bread he
came in with like a banana bread he
committed
i think about this he he i had to go
around and do all those i had to i was
i was psyched to do it with black
klansmen but you have to go to like you
know
20 shows or something and each one i'm
talking like the writer's guild
associate shows up and crushes and he's
like it's sag
things that aren't even televised i
don't know if he writes with someone or
if he just sits there and does it but
it's like
yeah things aren't even televised he's
crushing every single time let me tell
you this let me tell let me do you one
better
uh ben stiller when i won the
not the people's choice award like the
um young
oh young hollywood award oh yeah was
that is that like movie line
i don't i don't know movie line the
young like dot org not calm
what i want i think it was a razzy let's
be honest um
when i went out young hollywood the
comedian of the year like
bright smile awards literally just like
something like just a fake award show
that was like at someone's house
um and i hosted it and they're like who
do you want to present you with the
award i
hosted the young hollywood awards and
then i won best comedian they probably
just gave it to me because they're like
she's already here um and they're like
who do you want to present to you and i
literally was just like well i mean like
ben stiller
and he showed up and did it he wrote a
speech
where he read some of my tweets like
oh like he'd done research on it like
but yeah like the tweets at my tweets at
the time were like pretty wild did he
kill too
um like uh there was one tweet that was
um this was after two
girls one cup came out and i did i guess
i tweeted that day
the best part of waking up is two girls
in one cup
and he likes sang that tweet and like it
was just so
he he just shows up so hard i actually
did a pilot with him i got cast in that
pilot with john goodman
uh and justin bartha called the station
that was about um
david wayne ended up directing it
actually and i believe i got fired
um or recast i'm pretty sure i i was
recast
um and uh and stiller
produced it uh and was there every day
and was just like
just he's just such a dreamboat i
remember talking to busy phillips once
about this and i was like
ben stiller like why shouldn't he take a
break or a vacation like i just was like
you're at the top of the world
why why does he keep doing three movies
a year and she was like well that's why
he's on top of the world
i was just like like dum-dum that's
right let me ask you something because
as someone that
i know you're not gonna let me give you
this compliment um
but as truly like the
the catch of hollywood like you i think
you're like the catch of hollywood
and if you're if you're a sane person
we've gotten into like
a fictional territory yeah no no i'm
serious um
uh in terms of like you is my he's
coming from a girl who i hung out with a
lot
and never tried to make a pass of me
well because
i was very creeped out by famous people
at the time like i just was like
i i very much you know we both had some
kind of understanding
but you know that i'm super into animal
rescue and
that was it i hated animals he just i
hate him
dude one time i watched him um big
hunter i watched him hit a kitten with a
golf club
and i said you said why did you do that
i mean tears are running on your face
because i can
because the golf club was there because
i've just built my taxidermy room
um no i no there but i was scared of
celebrities i very much
saw celebrities at the time and i still
kind of do as like
sort of trapped people that everyone
wants a lot from
and i never like like i get really
uncomfortable when people
um use choke collars on dogs and ride
horses a certain way because they're
trapped and there's nothing and like
being objectified and um
in all fairness the horse didn't like
try out
a bunch of times to try to get the reins
on you know what i mean
for the job yeah i mean you know the
horses
three producers the horse saw
what uh what happened to other horses
and still decided
to put the reins on so you know not a
great example benton
i don't have a lot of friends but i have
a lot of fiends
i would never i am very relieved that i
am your best friend not your best feed
i would not want to be on your bad side
you want to you want to be on my best
fiends list though because my little
dudes are leveled up
my little creatures my little bugs they
are leveled up listen best fiends is a
it's free to download first of all it's
a puzzle game for your little brain
you know what it is it's like you fight
slugs one of the few things
that doesn't make me feel like my brain
is atrophying you're not getting
stupider it's so fun and engaging
it's a puzzle yes when you're waiting
for like 20 minutes when you're like in
la waiting um
four months to get a vaccine uh you it's
played in line
it is a healthy diversion on my phone
that keeps me
yeah you can't put into positive choices
you can't put it down it has over 100
million downloads
yeah people love it okay yeah i mean why
do they need it
it's for everyone it's for hardcore
gamers for casual gamers it's something
to do that'll make you
better in the long run because you're
exercising your noodle download best
fiends free today on the apple store or
google play that's friends without the r
best
fiends i am a psycho when it comes to
betting like i am the princess and the
pee
shocker which is crazy because i did not
grow up with fancy
like my mattress that is like the first
thing i spent money on
as an adult and betting and comforters
i like to spend days and days in bed
crying and i need it to be a soft place
to land
everything at brooklyn is quality the
comforters the sheets the pillowcases
the loungewear the but the towels
but here's my thing i hate being cold at
night which is why i
need a super warm comforter but when i
slip in i want the sheets to feel
cold and the pillow to feel cool and
then
it'd be warm these these uh
comforters they feel like the hug from
the dad that would have loved me brook
linen has 75 000 five star reviews so if
you don't believe us believe
you know 75 000 this is the only thing
the internet
has agreed to like treat yourself to
ultimate comfort with brooke lennon's
comforter collection go to brooklyn.com
and use promo code whitney to get 25
off with a minimum purchase of a hundred
dollars that's
dot b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com and enter
promo code whitney for twenty five
dollars off with a minimum purchase of a
hundred dollars
that's brooklyn.com promo code whitney
emily didn't wing for once
dean what happened the catch of
hollywood let's get back to that that's
where i'm going
yeah so i'm obsessed with and i've done
it with most of our guests like
guys especially um why your current wife
like what was different about her i
always want to give the fans especially
like
the female fans like like why her you
could have had anyone or you could have
had a lot of people
and i'm con i'm absolutely to say i'm
obsessed i know why because i've met her
and it's
very clear to me why she's the one but
why for you what was different
what you know because and i also want to
ask you about red flags because you have
such uh
sagacious like antenna with people you
do that is true i'm good at
no even now when i meet people i have
another dating you know like
i just can't handle that i get a weird
feeling about this guy you're so well
with a couple you know on like a couple
dates yeah i'll be like nah we're not
gonna do that
yeah yeah but you have a you have an
intuition that i've always really
admired as someone that surrounded
myself with toxic people
over and over again and just seemingly
cannot stop
you are always so good about like i mean
even i mean the the fact that we're
gonna
a boot like i mean those are the yeah
they're great guys they're great guys
best people
um why her when did you know man
it i always i'm going to talk about it
with you because you're my friend i
always hesitate to talk about it because
i
and she would love me to talk about it
so it's not like
she has a problem with me talking about
her this is being of service to the
girls in their 20s right now they're
like why doesn't that guy like me i
puked in his
honest who cares i'll tell you a story
about my wife and i never talk about it
but the first thing
i saw you guys together it was like it
was so weird because you're you're such
a unified
team like you you came to a party it was
the first time i met her
and you guys were like cracking each
other up yeah yeah she's like very funny
you guys were like in a little cocoon
but still being social but you didn't
you know uh dart and separate you like
still wanted to hang out
does that make sense yeah no it does i
mean it's a big part of
um well on a gut level i remember i
dated some people that i
that i liked but weren't um i don't know
if i had this
i felt like i was entertaining them a
lot oh jesus and she is
uh my wife is really funny i she doesn't
care to be uh funny to other people the
way you and i do yeah you know what i
mean like she's not like she doesn't
need to perform out of insecurity and
it's not like no
it's not like she's always on i don't
think anyone's ever cracked me up as
much in my life
and then on top of that okay well now
you're just being hurt
i mean i mean her first night to talk
you know what listen to her first night
in mbar
she killed it and it was like off the
dome she hadn't even prepared anything
she's the first woman i ever met that
made me laugh
she went to two different people's
houses
to not because i don't want to say who
it was but one of them was like
you know like your good friend kevin
spacey
yes and you know what's happened with
him is just tragedy yeah
i can't and i want to use the rest of my
time your best friend
brian singer yeah and oh like him too no
i uh
i uh just want to say i'm kidding
but um we went to like uh
this house that was in between like bono
and oprah's house
and it was lovely and i was like i've
been to some mansions in my time but i
was like holy shit
this is like incredible and then we went
to another house on the same day and
it was like a normal house on a kind of
like a cul-de-sac
where we had kind of left our car and as
we were driving home
uh this was out of town she was like um
i was talking about that mansion i mean
i was like i can't believe it in the
view and then she said no offense
but that's the kind of house that i want
and i was like
whoa uh whoa like i mean i would have to
do some
things really differently in my career
to and i also just thought that's too
bad she kind of
wanted she said no no the house by the
cul-de-sac the one that was like
and i was like oh what do you like like
i i didn't think it was right that she
wanted that big a mansion but i also was
like what do you mean like a house at a
you know like that let's not be let's
not be ridiculous i'm still tougher
graves
and she and she kind of walked me
through it and i was like oh my god this
person just naturally has this
philosophy that is um that
money doesn't buy any of these things
and i and i'm not valuable to her in
that
way you know amazing and and she wasn't
i mean she's like cuz i want to save all
your money for plastic surgery she
she has certainly spent uh not on
plastic surgery she has
grown more accustomed to spending my
money but uh she is
um she i like at her core i really think
that's like
she's just real that's just one of them
she's like real beliefs
about things that have kind of changed
me in terms of like
um i guess i thought you you knew me i
wasn't like
you said i was good with money or
whatever but i always thought like oh if
you have this much you should spend this
percentage of it and it's
uh the right thing to do it's only this
percent and then i realized like oh but
then if you have like 100 billion
dollars you got to have like a huge
house or something
and i realized no i you know that like
changed me into like wait what really
actually makes me happy
and she's done that to me in in so many
ways uh
probably without her knowing it but you
know just to hang out with someone just
the way you and i changed each other
yeah knowing each other you know you
know these people and then you
heard bill murray say it's like we're uh
we're all um
like meteoroids or something like just
kind of like yeah
headed to each other and then we connect
and we forever change the
trajectory of ourselves from having
connected you know
and i remember thinking though i
remember like i definitely met a ton of
girls that you had dated and ignored and
i always was
like dude he's never gonna find someone
smart enough for i was always like
i literally was like he's so because
he's so successful and ostensibly you
know
wealthy and all that kind of stuff um
and i was like he's just gonna attract
the wrong kind of people and that's so
sad because that's not what he wants you
know yeah that's true i had a moment
where i was like can i ask how you met
oh we met at a charity event wow at um
like a like i was there more in a kind
of like
celebrity way and she was she was there
for real
if she had proposed to you no there was
a thing that happened with us
early on where i was like
early on it was like we were definitely
in it probably saying i love you and
stuff and then she said
i i was saying something like you know
if we get married and have kids about
some house we're gonna buy or something
or she was like look we're obviously
getting married have kids so just like
and i was like oh okay didn't know you
follow it but i also was like
oh yeah of course we knew you know and
she said like i work in charity you're a
charity case so obviously with me
together
i can take care of you you might make a
wish i'm trying to make you like a
good person but she um she she did say
as a caveat to that like look if
something goes wrong we won't but let's
just operate like we are going to
because it'd be stupid to kind of
dance around like who knows if we're
gonna dude that is
she is my for that that is so awesome
yeah i agree and so i
to answer your question if she had after
that point said
we should get married or presented me
with a i don't know a ring and it's kind
of
a bill for the ring and the bill for the
reign that's what it is
it's just a bill in a circle this is the
bill for her ring right
put on my finger but she was uh i think
i would have been
fine with it i mean the only thing that
would mess it up is like
i was worried about like what does she
want me to do
so in that sense i understand what
you're going through because you go it's
a weird pop
i just feel like i'm obsessed with
friends of mine um
who uh or guys i know when they get
engaged because i have a lot of guy
friends and
i do feel like guys it's their last
opportunity to be in charge of something
in a way
that is more true than you like you know
what i mean this is your last hurrah of
being
in charge of a decision and planning it
fully yourself
let me tell you what happens when you
get down on one knee
like i was always like oh this would be
fun traditional thing people do this i
never thought about it
you're so fucked up all day you got this
ring in your pocket i didn't get that
term you know it's burning a hole in
your pocket i was like i gotta get this
thing off of me
that's so expensive here's the other
thing but i think that actually a couple
of my guy friends maybe that are way
less
emotionally uh well adjusted than you
kept the ring
way longer and waited a longer time to
propose
because i i think it's like the closest
you can ever
feel to being like in a jewelry heist
yeah you get to like hide a ring and
you're carrying a ring and you get to
like
i thought she was going to find out and
it was going to ruin her where did you
hide it
you know i had in my pocket like it was
you bought it and proposed the same day
no no no no no
no oh my god it was a whole thing that
tells me everything i need to know about
your credit i was doing a
i was doing a movie in australia and
the whole thing was was crazy i had to
have it shipped to my folks house which
was a mistake because my parents were
then like really in on it they pawned it
no no it was over she came home for
christmas i think and
over her shoulder my mom was like when
you
do that they make sure you get some
pictures and i was like mom like
she's hearing you like by the way and
the fact that this is how you think
pictures were taken
you mean by when it happened i was so
nervous it was good that i was gonna
ruin her story for life
by not but doing it right or whatever
and then when you
they're like for grace couldn't act like
he knew how to do it no way
he's an amazing actor no no no no no and
you've proposed to people in movies i
feel like
i have proposed to someone on film
before and i was much better at it this
was like i was so nervous and it's so
real
and then the act of get this is what i
will warn you is the act of getting down
on one knee
is really um
like there's i didn't understand the
emotional
like thing behind it but you're you're
basically like bowing down to someone
and and for good reason you know what i
mean it's making yourself so
vulnerable yeah yeah that's what it was
i was so
i was not prepared for how i mean i was
prepared i would feel vulnerable because
i was asking someone but it's also this
thing we've seen in
every movie for all of time princess
bride like it's so ingrained in our head
like
like just seeing a man get down on one
knee is just this like
we're so conditioned by that to be this
is the most
important moment of your life i think
it'd be great if i don't think anyone
would care i don't think any guy you
should be with
should care if you propose to him if
it's right the the fear i always had was
is this a hundred percent the right time
in the right way
the two stories i'll tell you is my
wife's getting such a kick out of this
i just never wind up talking about this
stuff is she
um actually i'm gonna tell you that
first story the second part
the second story is um is that
i will talk to you because you know what
she'll like it so much
she um i was like uh
some joke she said you know you joke
about proposals kind of before
it happened like way before it happened
and i was like you're ever lucky enough
to get her
you know propose to and she's like i've
been proposed to and i was like
oh okay
and the invite's still open okay and
that was a you gave that person a no so
like how did that work out i want to
know that whole story
and then the second
story was i forgot i'll come back what
were you asking for
oh don't pretend you first no no i
really did forget it was uh
but here's my thing about a lot of guys
i know overthink it
like i have one friend this is real and
i actually still want to make
this a movie about it um i just what's a
movie
um i a friend of mine went on a cruise
with his girlfriend's family oh boy
and said i'm going to propose on the
cruise i'm like great just do it on the
last day
just do it on the last day i you're
whitney you're so negative
you're stitching i'm like just do it on
the last day i just she's
trapped on a boat in the middle of the
ocean so i'm just saying
do it on the last day he panicked did it
on the first day
she said no he was on a cruise with her
family
and her for the next week that's a movie
yeah
i was like yeah you're stuck and then
he's trying to meet other people on the
boat he's trying to rebound with other
girls
like on and it's her time actually that
is a movie yeah the entire family is
there i mean it was like 45 people it
was like a family it was like her dad's
80th birthday oh god oh my god and every
and they're literally
and i was like dude he just panicked um
and
uh and just like when guys overthink
like i'm just like think this through
yeah i think yeah it was uh i was very
nervous how'd you pick out the ring
i i i you know it's funny the minute you
decide you're gonna do it
you immediately become duplicitous
you're like you know hiding behind the
person's back and trying to you know
i can't tell you how many peop before my
uh uh
uh former fiance proposed to me i was
convinced she was cheating for three
months because he was like on his phone
he wouldn't let me see his phone his
phone was like he was like calling her
friends and i remember i called her
friend and
yeah no no our friend who
i was um involved in the planning of her
engagement
thought i was having an affair with her
husband because we were texting each
other all the time
so funny that's what happened i called
her number and the guy
picked up her phone like hello like
who is that you know what i mean like
which dude is calling and i was like hey
i'm
and i do immediately be like so you know
i know i've told anyone this but i'm
gonna propose and he was like oh my god
here's where's my hey here's my wife
yeah it's like so much weird shit comes
up and but the ring
i i'm glad you called girlfriends
because every guy i know calls their guy
friends for ring advice i'm like what
are you doing
that's what you're doing that's when
someone ends up with a yellow diamond
liken sex in the city and then how did
you pick your band
or just no i had the a different friend
go with her and say
hey what your wedding band oh my wedding
i thought you meant her uh
you know my wife didn't care just go go
get something we got that in case it's
replaceable
did it feel weird to wear jewelry as a
man it it did i did it in movies
a couple times and i was like we got it
your movies are this
just felt weird but uh but it was
probably more emotionally weird than it
was
physically weird um and your father
so yeah i know that's not i mean you and
i right now are
in the part of the movie that takes
place at the end
like you think the movie's over and it's
going to credits and then it pulls up
and it's like
you know 15 years later we're like on
this and this is us and we're like
older and taller looking back on the
thing but we really that really felt
like it's probably because it was our
first
everything so speak for yourself i
probably look younger now than i did
back then
you look great thank you but like you
that was so
you know everyone knows it when they're
going through it but you can't hold on
to it enough it's so
also so it's like it's i like you
i don't know i just i i definitely had
thought this before like
you're probably just like the most fun
dad ever
you know what i you know what i suffered
from are you too fearful no no no i'm
not i think i'm a fun dad i mean you
have to ask
my kids i think when i was younger
around when you knew me
if i had a complaint it was that i think
people thought of me as a fun dad then
yeah no totally but i wasn't a dad you
know what i mean like i was like i
wanted to
you know date people and i would never
take my actual children to disneyland
crazy but i kind of you know i
like we i am kind of a fun i've had this
feeling since i've turned 40 where i'm
like i think i'm kind of more
what i was kind of meant to be it was
it's a bummer to be
there were plenty of girls when when we
were in our 20s that i
were like oh you know someday you seem
like you're going to be fine but
right now i'm going to get with the
right the bad boy
whatever whoever it was it's a deep cut
that's a deep cut
but um but i do i yeah i feel
really great and i love it and i i think
i'm good at it
do you um i'm just terrified i know i'm
gonna have kids
they might be built in the lab or
adopted who knows but i
the way that i'm with my dog like i am
so terrified because so much bad
happened to me when i was a kid like i
caught on fire and i and i hurt myself
all the time
like i'm just do you just eventually let
it go
or you always kind of like physically
physical
hurt or just like like breaking your arm
right like i just
we can't bubble wrap our kids but like
does the fear ever really go away
well now you're a protector of something
there are better people to ask than me
i'm not i'm not uh i'm not like a
super dad but i do think uh like i've
met them a couple times they seem lovely
i think uh yeah you know gosh if i could
just remember their names
they're so sweet um uh
the my wife is like we were talking
about
very into their physical safety and of
course care deeply that they're
physically safe
but mostly there's kind of after a while
nothing you can
you can't watch them every minute of
them live and some of it's about like
you they gotta fall down and scrape
their knee and then they learn not to
do that thing on the listen to what you
say yeah so
i and i and i do hold my breath for oh
my god there's gonna be a
moment where there's a you know someone
breaks their arm and you know so i
hate all of them so that's why we don't
use seat belts i mean they have to learn
to they gotta learn
you know what i mean they gotta learn
and uh and then
but what i do worry about is uh
mentally what you're passing on and i
mean i'm sure you can't help that stuff
either to be honest but you know yeah
and also
they really do what you do not what you
say and so it's like oh i guess i have
to be a fucking take care of myself
because they're just gonna do what i do
a lot of that
and also just a lot of like what i'm
thinking about lately
is like i'm in someone else's youth
like isn't that crazy you know what i
mean someone's like deep youth you know
what i mean like they're like those
memories that you have that are like
from when you're
really young that form your whole vision
of the world and it's a big
responsibility how are you documenting
them like when i watched the periscope
and documented the woody allen
documentary i was like i have no videos
from my childhood
we don't even want to be turning on
cameras that much because
we we grew up around a lot of people who
and wait we're people who like attention
and we don't that's part of the thing i
don't want
somebody they'll steal your thunder fair
that's it they're so cute
and they you know when you're with them
in a picture i feel like people are
looking at them
and they just look older next to them
that's the other thing too
yeah so focus we do videos just for us
you know what i mean but i see it i see
people with their with their um
uh uh kids and they're just sitting here
filming their kid and filming their kid
and i'm like you guys the kid doesn't
know what you're doing
it just looks like you care about this
black box to them it's the new form of
alcoholism around your kid i swear like
kids now like this is where parents tune
out i think that's true and maybe not
filming them but about you know anything
that's on the phone
that box that they're the cigarette
they're the cigarettes it's more
important than me
like that's more important i must be a
real piece of shit that that black box
that they don't know what it does
they don't know how important it is but
they're even they don't they just think
it's a black box they don't know that
it's better than them like
how do they know that it's like way more
valuable than them no i i
do we're look this is all my wife so i'm
talking about
her her values which i really fell in
love with um
in addition to her we don't do any
screens and uh
she gets on me when i'm looking at my
phone and uh it's hard by the way doing
no screens i always thought like yeah
that's the healthy way to this is why
you don't know how famous you are you
don't go on the internet okay so i
ate these yogurt pretzels and now
they're i've put them on my lap and
they've melted
and now it just looks like you put them
on there here take some of them no it
just looks like i
auditioned for brett oh my god do you
love that i could just don't give a fuck
well i don't think you're gonna make
many enemies by making that joke
i'm just saying like there's something
that happens i think when
the pandemic happened and comedians all
of a sudden we're able to do podcasts
that are
more lucrative than a lot of tv at this
point um
and not needing the industry where it's
wonderful it's that kind of freedom
don't you feel lately like with
comedians they're lifting each other up
more than
like that was not the culture when you
and i no it was it's me or you for this
job it's me or you for this especially
these women it was like there's only one
woman on every line up you're my
competitor you're my hero but i hate you
you know it's like because it's me or
you
now it's like we all lift each other up
and the
podcast is helping that uh that happen
right because everyone's helping
they literally have to call on your
friends you know my favorite part about
this is is that
it's it used to be survival of the most
savage or survival of the most ambitious
or the most
um uh uh it was never the nice guy
won right for a long time for sure yeah
you know
um but uh you're the anomaly there but
now it's like with podcasts and stuff
it's about who will do you a favor and
come and talk to you for three hours
for you know and a lot of you can tell
the people that have podcasts that were
to comics coming up 10 years ago
because no one will show up there's a
certain number think about the comedians
that don't
appear as guests on podcast very often
you know and
i was doing it was used to be i mean
doing you know rogan uh
by the time i did rogan he was already
the biggest i mean
getting 90 million downloads a month but
um
uh like tom segura bert kreischer uh
uh brandon shaw but all these podcasts
that are now huge theo vaughn
um that were huge when i first did them
i was doing them a favor
but i drove down to santa monica did my
jury duty did their podcast now their
podcasts are huge and now they'll come
on mine and help me
you know so now it's kind of survival of
the nicest that's so interesting i never
heard explain like that but it's like
is that a beautiful thing the internet
finally did something good for people
if you were there's a lot of over
correction and there's a lot of like
people like getting
that i don't think they really deserve
but um and we're sort of now just
getting so addicted
to the the town square of like yeah but
yeah but i i like what you're saying
because it's uh yeah
you know you were a dick 10 years ago
you
to even the the pa or the craft services
person like
everyone has twitter now everyone can
weigh in now i mean there's all these
these these instagram feeds that pop up
or um people that work at airports are
like yeah i met so-and-so and she was a
total
she was being shit like everyone that
you
never thought could help or hurt you
that you just thought were invisible
there was a solution back then which is
just being nice to people but no i'm
saying but but like
the people that were to the comics
coming up yeah yeah
they're getting all the power or the
minorities and the women the ones that
are starting to get power
are like uh probably should have been
nicer yeah probably shouldn't have
called me
in the green room who are we talking
about specifically right now uh we're
talking about david spade
for real no okay he's the nicest guy
ever i know i've had a
very pleasant experience that was a
really hard thing because i was like oh
there's so many people that they would
not think that was a joke
never um uh but he
and and yeah it's like spade like you
know like and also just like
we hung out so long ago like we became
friends like he comes to my like
the fact that i can get the kind of
guests i can get i'm really proud cause
i'm like i feel like
there's a lot of opportunities i didn't
get or a lot of jobs i didn't get
because i didn't have like a cutthroat
mentality and i was very like now it's
kind of that's paying off yeah i'm like
no you go you go and i'm like
i feel like i've wasted so much
potential by not fighting harder to like
get on snl or like
like not being so compe like i just i
always wanted people to like me in the
hallways
and if the audiences were lukewarm on me
i was like okay well the comment the
comedians
opinions matter more well you did both
really i mean you know what i mean you
can and you can do
you know you can do both but like if you
were if you're a womanizer if you were
ready to wear
like you it's the jig is up you know
yeah the people that work are the ones
that are kind and a lot of the reason
that i
even your off-camera behavior um uh
it's weird because i think part of the
reason i'm so scared to
keep doing tv at least as a creator is
that
you have 200 people like one i mean you
have 10 people in a cast
let's say one person's bad behavior 10
years ago or misjudgment 10 years ago
can ruin everything you've built
so now it happened to me with roseanne i
mean she
really built it but by the time i came
in and ran it it's like we worked our
asses off blood sweat and tears like i
could not have put more into
you know epping that show and then one
tweet and it's all over
you know can i tell you though that
that's how everything i don't think i've
said this to you but i or maybe i have
but that
that whatever the new pilot was so the
new first episode for the reboot
i couldn't believe it and it was
impactful for me going back to network
now just because i thought oh you can
just abc yeah you you can do it you
somehow i mean
reunions should never work i mean just
the nature of it should never work and
it
really worked i mean i didn't i was uh i
don't think we had kids yet i don't
think so i
kind of like wasn't going to tune in
every week yeah anything that was on
network because i was like out
yeah but uh but i remember watching that
out of curiosity
and just thinking wow i can't believe
they
they got it right and i knew you i think
i knew you were on it at that point and
it was like
uh not only that i think we got it right
for because there were lots of brilliant
people
uh involved laurie metcalf would come in
because when you're like on a multicam
you're like oh this script is going to
change you're kind of just reading it
during the run-throughs and then she'd
commit like a thousand
she's in her stefan wolfe hoodie there
before
anyone with her doing her pr knowing her
things and do
and then destroys with three i mean
three hours of prep
still kills it and i just went up to her
once and i was very scared to talk to
her like i was just
like truly intimidated her and john
goodman both
um john goodman i was so intimidated by
every time he would ask me a question i
would just start lying
like totally by accident and because i
just would panic
but but it's not a mistake that's what
i've learned these people that are great
i mean because those people have been
great in other mediums too you can see
it's like
i was lucky the first couple films i did
it was like julie roberts well with the
when i was in with ginny and yeah
and uh dennis quaid dance created
something i went oh it's like
like they don't have time for all that
bull they're so busy
making it good and trying and they have
no ego and
yeah the hardest working the one usually
the people that are those on the set
either aren't prepared or they're they
know they don't deserve to be there
and they need to like distract or create
yeah that's right that's so right and
the people are the most qualified are
the most like
just pros these i mean the people that
especially in multicam it drives me
crazy that actors on multicams don't get
the same kind of respect and recognition
really
because it is such an art form it is so
hard to
do uh and it really is like doing
theater and to also be subtle and
and by with the kind of angles because
you don't get to have these like super
close close-ups in multi-cams that's
something i've noticed doing this new
one is i'm like
like bring the camera in like i'm just
not going to have to push it so hard i
can do this like i don't have to be like
darling certainly done my share of
darn it yeah but um but yeah so that
to me like that was just devastating
like the idea of you know i did a tv
show with an actor that got
you know were there any red flags with
roseanne no i'm just kidding i mean
i mean you did it you know what i mean
like uh a it was a red
flag um the russian flag actually
correct
um uh yeah there was a uh
you know it's it's tricky because i'm
and i think part of the reason i'm like
kind of
whatever on hollywood right now and i'm
i'm i'm this space and stand-up is more
exciting for me is because hollywood
there is this just like elitist like so
left-wing that they won't even admit
that right wing or conservative people
exist or people without money exist
and well that was always the brilliant
thing about that show i mean i watched
it more when it was on the first time
but
when it was on the first time she was
hard left actually
you know that's right super aggressive i
just mean it didn't seem to have any
um it wasn't allegiant to anything
except for the truth
but in comedy there's this new thing
where you can't have
characters that you disagree with or
it's like offensive i mean some of the
greatest characters
in in television history whether it's
like archie bunker you're gonna say
yeah i mean you know but even even al
bundy they'd be like he's sexist and
he's objectifying his wife it's like get
get what i mean archie bunker one's a
better example because it really
said something i'm not sure what mary
children said in broadway
theater in plays like there is a
glorification of the working class
person whether it's like willie lowman
or um some
uh tennessee williams plays i see what
you're saying that was kind of like a
version
tennessee williams was married with
children it's so great with children is
to me
uh just as important as cattle hunting
roof
um fair enough mary with children and
martin were two
were very uh instrumental martin when
that was firing when we were in
still the funniest stick i'm ever i mean
still because oh and i didn't tell you
about the uh jeannie garofalo thing with
ellen
i'm obsessed with when multicams break
the rules i mean like when cosby at the
end the finale they pan to the audience
don't think that's gonna be his legacy
but it was well done um
and martin there was an episode where he
opened the uh
um window and jumped out and then all
the crew members
jumped out after him it was just this
weird thing where he like broke the
fourth wall it was like wild and then
you can tell by i think it was like
season three
him and um yeah something happened on
the show
the first one or two seasons were do you
remember that um
i've gone and watched this on youtube
because i think it's one of the funniest
moments i've ever seen on tv
where he starts giving her a speech but
you don't realize until halfway
because she's left in which was another
guy starts giving her a speech you
realize it's that whitney houston song
which is a big hit on the radio at the
time that i will always love you
but he's like so you go but at first you
just think it's like
so good and he walks through it and
what's great is hearing the audience
realize like at the moment the penny
drops we're like oh my god this is all
the lyrics to that song
and then he just keeps but he also
played shanae
the neighbor i mean i mean dude i still
watch that show it is
and also some of my favorite shit which
i feel like people don't do anymore this
is actually my main qualm with snl is
like
to me some of the best sketches are the
ones that fall apart and everyone's
breaking and laughing
like yeah i
everyone likes it everyone likes it i'm
saying bill hader cracking up during the
the club promoter obviously kristen wing
and armistan doing um
the singers what is it um garth and cat
like that's my favorite
kate mckinnon like she's a genius but in
that alien abduction sketch would she
she's like well she makes everyone else
breaking that
gosling was laughing yeah like i love
that you know but then when melissa
mccarthy my favorite of all time sketch
of all time was the tasting the ranch
bit and she's so
she's yeah it's it's one or the other
right yeah
like uh melissa mccarthy she wouldn't
yes she was on mike molly
oh i thought you meant like uh gilmore
girl like or
that was she kind of hit and then she
did mike and molly right true that's
true maybe that's right
but she like you know became a movie
star off of it and then we're just like
she's a genius like she was on a
multicam
oh no she's yeah i mean she's oh my god
she's incredible like some of the stuff
on snl
you know we have uh not just sashir but
nora dunn plays my mom on the show
dude well here's my only reason to bring
it up is
don't wasn't that the best snl cast what
is the best snl cast in your opinion
i think it's got to be phil hartman jan
hooks dana carvey like
but then everyone my favorite sketch of
all time is landshark so i would have to
say chevy chase even though i know he's
fallen from grace
i mean look the original cast is great
but i think like shabby chased dan
aykroyd coneheads
i mean that that was real landshark okay
best cast not original cast
that could be will ferrell you know oh
young people of
lonely island is it for them now it's
like it's really i forget like
like i kristen whit i mean yeah i mean
kristin the christian rig gears has to
be
that is the lonely island right yes uh
will was there i can't tell it was armas
in there i mean yeah
armistan might be my all-time favorite
cast member i think i think it's gotta
be phil hartman like i think
there's not anyone on that show who
wouldn't tell you it's that he's the
mack daddy like i i but
it's funny there's this thing i hosted
it once and i said i was saying that
because the
creators of 70s show were head writers
on snl
at that time with phil hartman and those
cats
and i was saying to lauren like isn't
this like
the you know like it wasn't that the
best cat in your opinion and he was like
you know what was the greatest uh like
period in science fiction writing
and it's when you were 13 years old like
whatever you know
and i was like oh that's true you know
we were like talking around the cast and
it was like
i feel that way about that cast
and then caitlyn was like i feel that
way about will ferrell because she's
younger than me and then
jimmy who like really came up on youtube
and stuff was like i don't know some of
that lonely island stuff and i was like
oh
i really don't know but i still would
take norway when tracy morgan
used to do that um talk show
i mean there's maybe it's like on maybe
you can't really figure it out yeah
it's yeah there were different for
different reasons because yeah when i
was growing up landshark was like me and
my dad's inside
like i loved it so much because it was
like you know made us
laugh together i feel like if i look
back at it now i'd be like this is
random
um wild and then uh it's also yeah it's
the time in which you watch it yeah
but in the years that i don't like were
the years that i
auditioned i feel the same way about a
lot of movies out there
problem that's the problem with like you
asked me like why don't you watch more
movies because i auditioned for half of
them and i don't want to
watch alice and brie be amazing in it
when i didn't get it like it's
this is my theory of why people like
comedians are so miserable it's like
yes we didn't start that way it's just
that when you start doing it
you as a business and as a field and
everyone
becomes a competitor to you instead of
you can just
you lose the ability to enjoy the things
that most people
use to relax and check out so movies and
tv that's what everyone does to tune out
when i watch movies and tv or stand up
i'm like i should
so what relax it's hard to find joy in
it anymore so that's why i
mostly watch old movies during them oh
yeah pandemic i watched
re-watch labyrinth almost once a month
old movies
well you were philadelphia story or
something
always i i finally got back to the back
to the future trilogy
and just some of those nuances and
whatever i decided to watch sweet home
alabama yeah
but the old guess what it still works
um and uh i watched charlie the
chocolate factory the original
have you watched that recently yeah that
was very nightmare inducing for me when
i was a kid i really
i'm still scared by that movie dude
watching it now is
wild yeah yeah it's all the kids die
yeah it's but don't they kind of come
back in the understanding kind of like
they're ghosts or something they would
have died though as an adult
you're like as a kid you're like they
came back and as you know you're like
that would have helped no
i remember it as just being a horror
house when i was a kid i didn't get it
yeah it's a con
it's a commentary on uh people that
don't give their children consequences
it was a comment on parenting
right on bad parenting and at the time i
was just like kids in chat like it's
wild to look back and now looking back
you can see how everything was made with
like poster board
like the magic is totally right i gotta
watch it again you have to watch it
again because you see that like the
mushrooms are just made out of like
painted baseball bats
the way that they like the 70s feels
like such a chill
time to make movies like i mean there
were some great movies made then too but
but i mean generally it was like
whatever guys dude my obsession now is
with
what happened behind the scenes on the
movies we loved as children
the wizard of oz do you realize that the
scarecrow
had to no the tin man the original cast
member of the tin man
he because he got poisoned because he
got poisoned the they were using
zinc and arsenic as the sp face paint
uh the the uh the director
um uh what's your name judy garland was
laughing so hard uh and couldn't do a
take that he slapped her in the face
like it's like that was every movie back
then yeah it was every movie
get it together and then uh yeah just
like all the crazy went on like behind
the scenes of that movie oh the witch
because the um the the with the green
face uh whatever that was was so
flammable that it was like burning her
skin off and she caught on fire like
numerous times like
there's a great sketch the it's
christopher guest did a
for the oscars when billy crystal was
hosting this a couple
maybe 10 years ago um he uh
does the like um a research group for
the wizard of oz and it's like all in
black and white footage
so it's just like this was a filmed
research you know those terrible groups
of people who go
anyway they it's uh kind of a funny
sketch because they're all giving their
input on why the movie is bad
but then catherine o'hara goes she's so
brilliant
am i nuts or was one of those ladies
green i know i think might have been
fred uh what's
uh fred willard my nutsert was one of
those ladies green
fred willard i don't it's a weird it's a
weird one did you ever get into mad tv
or no
that was always like the like sloppy
like
bastard child of snl it was all the
people that didn't make it when i first
started i was in high school yeah i
watched a little bit of it but kind of
maybe
i definitely the most embarrassing thing
that's ever happened to me was when i
auditioned for
mad tv to me that's really what
we get paid for like when people say
like actors get paid too much it's like
we do
so much for free for we don't get most
jobs you know i think it's weird that
actors don't get paid to audition then
writers don't get paid to pitch
yeah i guess there aren't a lot of other
jobs that are like that where you do so
much work do a month of work you pitch a
show and have no guarantee that they're
you know especially as like show runners
like i'm doing this thing at apple um
the bunga bunga the silvio berlusconi
story and like it was really wave slow
down what is that sylvia berlusconi he
was the um
prime minister of italy and was like
super corrupt and very much like a
predecessor to trump 80s 90s up until
yeah i did like i uh i narrated the
wondery podcast about him and so i'm i
should know way more um frankly but and
then you got the rights
yeah wonder you got it um and then i uh
narrated it because he was very um
uh untoward with women and inappropriate
so it was like having to
tell the story without glorifying him or
you know so it was like i i kind of i
feel like was a good
match for it in a weird way he was the
trump of uh he was
owned tv stations in real estate and he
put himself on tv
he knew anything about this he bought
the i mean trump and him
i mean he like literally wrote the
playbook for trump got the playbook from
vladimir putin and then it's like
like when you hear it it's it's so um
concurrent like it's so wild he was like
a playboy he had these parties called
bunga bunga parties where he would have
these
uh girls dress up he did um uh
these shows these driving shows with
show girls and he got them elected to
parliament so he got
all of his cronies to be part like it
was just so wildly corrupt he was like
very connected to the mafia
but also very outwardly disgusting
and it made people love him more because
he was so shameless about it he lived in
this huge mansion
that is very prescient yeah yeah and
everyone was like you're one of us
like and he had a gold toilets you know
it was just but he
he spoke in a very prosaic way in his
mantra was go italy
like a sports like he very much
approached politics as a sport
yeah i know like mike was good at
marketing basically marketing himself
that was it so he that he had the tan he
had the bad hair
like the whole thing well i gotta watch
this he's amazing i love you i'm gonna
let you go
home economics can i take this with me
yes i mean please
no i'll if anyone listen to this point
they're aware of home economics
they're listening and yes you can have a
copy of my book just hit my memo
um and uh you want me to sign it joking
um also home economics on abc
now i'm saying don't plug it why not why
not
because because uh people want to see
good television
if anyone listened to an hour and a half
of us doing this
then they are well aware of everything
that you and i are up to people
in jail that finish these till the end
um
all right but uh home economics i i i
look i don't say
i don't bring anyone on podcasts like
i'm pretty we're pretty picky over here
for some reason just because
i'm too embarrassed to go watch this
show like i can't co-sign on something
that i don't truly think is good or else
i
well we should we should promote it
because of sashir
is amazing no the ch i laughed out loud
at the trailer like it to me
just like it's about money it's
heartfelt it's funny i know okay let me
tell you something
i just i'm trying to get a guest i am i
am glad
that i came on because i wanna i wanna
hold on
i'm available to play uh topher grace's
uh
uh a nasty ex-wife who has schizophrenia
and um is coming back to try to get
impregnated by the rich one
you you are i really mean this one of my
favorite people i cannot believe that we
made it all the way through
to here the best
[Music]
one four four four four
[Applause]
you